il y a 2 ans qu néonazis ont attaqué ma
famille dans notre maison sur le lac et
assassiné mon
père aujourd'hui j'ai 16 ans j'ai
déserté trois familles d'accueil Diego
viens cette femme c'est Helena je vis
avec elle depuis un
an quelques informations sur ce groupe
au naaz ils se sont baptisés les nobelem
et il se pourrait qu'il débarqu à
filmort s'il devait faire une apparition
à filmort ce mercredi nul ne saurait
mesurer la forme de leur intervention tu
nous installes vite fait ou tu vas
rester planté là
suivez-moi quand
même je suis sûr qu'elle l'a fait
exprès
Diego
[Musique]
die à notre grande nation à la mission
vengeresse que nous allons accomplir
pour les hommes à la liberté à la
LI qui sa
c'est la vengance sanglante d'une
adolescente tu as enlevé mon
chien je de
MRE dans ma pour l'insurrection de
demain
divertissant
les meilleures choses ont une faim ah
mais c'est pas fini Becky
[Musique]
enragé